it's hard to make predictions especially
about the future but that's exactly what
we'll try to do in this video 2021 was a
strange year there was a big regime
change we finally beat the pandemic and
everybody took off their masks and went
back to the office that was the original
plan anyway unfortunately it's your
conspiracy theorist uncle on facebook
who keeps making the right predictions
but as developers and entrepreneurs we
don't care about these externalities we
figure out ways to make money writing
code with the environment they give us
we thrive in the chaos if you're new
here like and subscribe then we'll start
things off by looking at major trends
that will influence the developer
landscape in 2022 then for each trend
i'll give you one of my personal weird
app ideas that you can use to build a
quadrillion dollar startup the first
trend we need to talk about is web3 or
the decentralized web some people think
web 3 is the point where all modern
technology converges out of which new
unimaginable technologies will diverge
in the future other people though think
that web 3 is just the latest buzzword
to pump crypto scams but what is web3
exactly a completely decentralized
version of our current internet with no
firewalls no tolls no
government regulation
you want to build a new internet
yes it's basically a vision for the
internet where everything is
decentralized and regulated with smart
contracts and crypto instead of the
current status quo where everything is
controlled by google facebook and amazon
in a decentralized app or dap the user
owns all their data instead of an email
password identity users are identified
by a blockchain wallet address that
usually connects with a browser plugin
like metamask while the app itself is
code that lives on the blockchain in the
form of a smart contract the idea is
really cool because it gives people real
control over their own slice of the
internet as opposed to using services
that are mediated by a central ivory
tower like a big tech corporation or
government on the other hand there are a
ton of ways one might criticize web3
it's chaotic hard to develop quality
apps with current tool chains it doesn't
benefit most mainstream businesses in
any practical way most of the tokens are
owned by silicon valley insiders so it's
not really decentralized at all and you
really don't need cryptocurrency to
build a decentralized app in the first
place if crypto prices collapse for
whatever reason i think a lot of the
excitement for web 3 would disappear i
could go on but one of my favorite
quotes is pessimist sounds smart but
optimists make money building a
decentralized internet is not an easy
thing to do there's a huge opportunity
for developers who are willing to tackle
the problems in this space a big part of
success is timing facebook google and
amazon were all in the right place at
the right time to capitalize on web 1.0
and 2.0 i think you should be skeptical
about web3 but if it does go mainstream
you'll be very glad you got in early a
full web 3 tutorial is on the way so
make sure you're subscribed to my
channel now here's my web3 startup idea
it's pretty obvious that the corporate
media is dying not many people in the
key demo actually trust or watch the
mainstream media but they can continue
to force feed us this content by making
it artificially rank high on platforms
like twitter and youtube and even by
removing things like the dislike button
to limit our ability to point out bad
content what i think would be awesome is
an entirely decentralized news network
where journalists could upload video
articles and other reporting and be
compensated based on its reach it would
incentivize good journalism and
eliminate the possibility of a top-down
propaganda machine journalists win
consumers win the only one who gets
[ __ ] is the establishment and now a
word from our sponsors hi my name is
jeff and i'm a 10x developer and you can
be one too if you start every day with a
hearty breakfast from mcdonald's like
the sausage egg mcmuffin value meal
available for a limited time for under
14 remember guys real developers eat at
mcdonald's i'm loving it
and that brings us to our next trend the
metaverse you likely saw mark
zuckerberg's ultra cringe i mean
inspiring vision about the metaverse i
pulled the channel and the majority of
you thought the vision was dumb i
totally agree with that because i would
never want to be involved in any kind of
metaverse run by facebook a company with
a terrible track record of abusing our
data and violating our privacy that
being said facebook is not the only
company building a metaverse they're
just trying to hijack the name the
general concept is to build an
internet-based platform that has
multiple access points like your phone
vr and ar then you have a single profile
that you can use to interact with
different businesses and apps within
that platform and communicate with other
users in a virtual environment like you
would in vrchat or an old school app
like second life the concept is actually
really cool but i don't think the vr
aspect of it will ever go super
mainstream vr has been around for a long
time now and the technology is really
good but most people just don't like
using it we already know we're addicted
to social media and video games the idea
of strapping on a headset to further
detach from the real world just doesn't
seem like something that humans will do
that being said metaverses are being
built and there will be opportunities
there for developers if you want to get
into it learning something like unity or
unreal engine would be a good place to
start or 3d modeling software like
blender here's my startup idea there's a
lot of hype and investment going into
the metaverse and during a gold rush
it's a good idea to sell shovels the
idea is to create something like a
squarespace or shopify for the metaverse
a platform where any business can build
some kind of digital metaverse
experience ar and vr apps are extremely
hard to develop if you can give brands a
way to get their foot into the door of
the metaverse there are likely millions
of potential customers out there that
will want to interact with customers on
the metaverse but don't have the
technical skills to get the job done now
let's switch gears to the next trend
artificial intelligence ai has come a
long way in the last couple years and in
2021 it affected us developers
personally with the release of github
co-pilot which is a tool that uses ai to
automatically write code for you it's
not to the point where it's going to
replace developers but i'm sure we'll
get there someday the one thing that's a
little disappointing about ai is that
it's kind of dominated now by big
companies that have control of these
algorithms like gpt3 it would be
extremely difficult as an individual or
startup to train ai models that can
compete with it for one you won't have
the massive amount of data needed and
two you won't have the computing power
point two will become especially true if
quantum computers ever become useful if
a quantum computer can train an ai model
then it's pretty much game over that
being said it's still a good idea to
learn data science because it's still
very difficult to process and analyze
huge amounts of data and that means
there's a lot of high paying jobs out
there for that role here's my startup
idea if you can't beat them join them
microsoft has exclusive access to gpt-3
but there's still a public api where you
can use gpt3 to build a product a lot of
people like to interact with psychics
but that business model doesn't scale
very well because you need to meet with
each client individually what you could
do is use gpt 3 to create an ai driven
psychic hotline where customers could
interact with lost loved ones and gpt3
would automatically generate responses
that come from the other side now i want
to take a minute to talk about something
a little more boring databases a trend
that i've noticed is that relational sql
databases are back in vogue sql has
always been the most widely adopted type
of database but now it's a cool
technology to use again we're also
seeing ai being implemented into
databases like mindsdb to make machine
learning workflows much easier in
addition you have tools like planetscale
and supabase who are making relational
databases much easier to work with at
the same time you have no sql databases
like mongodb becoming more and more
powerful which can now be deployed in a
serverless way and supports full text
search then you have redis becoming a
multi-model database to support graph
time series and full text search
features then you have firestore from
firebase which really didn't change in
2021 but i'm going to keep my fingers
crossed for some new features in 2022.
if not the serverless sql platforms are
looking very appealing here's my startup
idea databases are boring but boring
ideas are also ideas that can make money
if you identify a trend in the industry
that's going to require a lot of
specialized developers consider building
a job board it's a really easy app to
make and if you market it well it can
make a ton of money like over seven
figures you just need to find a
specialized segment of the market then
build up a big email list the next big
trade i want to talk about is javascript
always bet on javascript if you learn
javascript you'll never go hungry last
year i predicted that we're mostly done
seeing changes to the big frameworks of
react angular and vue and that
prediction has held true the core
frameworks are pretty much the same
react concurrent mode is still
experimental just as it was last year
while angular and vue remain solid and
stable all the exciting stuff is
happening with the meta frameworks next
js is the leader in the space and its
parent company versel is now a
multi-billion dollar company what we've
done over the last 20 years is come full
circle originally we had server rendered
applications then we went to client
rendered applications and now we have
things like next js which provide the
best of both worlds next version 3 and
the view ecosystem looks absolutely
incredible but it's not feature complete
at the time of this video we also have
react server components around the
corner and that's led to new frameworks
like hydrogen from shopify there's also
remix that we looked at in a previous
video but the most interesting
development in my opinion is the fact
that rich harris the creator of svelt
was hired by vercell to work on spelt
full-time everybody knows that svelt is
the greatest ui framework ever created
but it came a little too late in the
game and never had the financial backing
of a big company that's about to change
which makes me feel very optimistic
about the future of svelt kit a
framework for server side rendering in
addition to meta frameworks you'll also
want to keep your eye on meta meta
frameworks one example is blitz js which
is built on top of next and makes it
much easier to build a database driven
application another really cool
javascript tool worth mentioning is
astro which allows you to build a
website using one or multiple frameworks
at the same time without sending any
javascript down to the client build
tools for front-end developers also
improved a ton in 2021 the best example
is veet which provides a far simpler
developer experience compared to
something like webpack it's much faster
and way easier to work with here's one
way that you as an independent developer
can make money around meta frameworks
you might be familiar with sites like
themeforest that sell premium wordpress
templates many of which are based on
react vue and angular however if you're
building a server rendered application
with a meta framework these themes
aren't very useful i think there's an
opportunity here to create custom server
render templates that can help other
developers get things done faster like
next already has an ecommerce template
but there's an infinite number of
variations you can make on this and also
provide other templates for e-learning
small businesses enterprise dashboards
real estate and all kinds of other
industries now because next is server
rendered you can do things beyond the ui
like integrate stripe as a payment
solution or include sendgrid for
transactional email we now apparently
have microscopic robots that can
reproduce that being said here's some
other information that you'll want to
know going into 2022. jetbrains is
releasing a new lightweight ide fleet
that could compete with vs code the s
code itself is better than ever and you
can now run it directly in the browser
tailwind css is becoming more and more
popular and it got especially awesome in
2021 thanks to just in time mode
typescript is also more popular than
ever and we have some cool new features
coming to the javascript language like
at to get a negative index or the last
element in an array we have top level
weight standardized and a much more
ergonomic way to use object prototype
has own property in 2022 graphql is
still not going to replace rest and the
hype around it seems to have died down
quite a bit webassembly is not going to
replace javascript but it is quietly
changing the world one example is stack
blitz which brings server-side
capabilities to the browser no code is
still a trend to keep your eye on but
it's still not going to take your job as
a developer just like it hasn't for the
last 50 years when it comes to mobile
development flutter and react native
will continue to dominate the
cross-platform space you might see brain
interfaces like neurosity where you
write code they can react to changes in
your brain waves aws will continue to
release a bunch of products you don't
need while google cloud and azure
continue to play catch-up the only
prediction i'm 100 confident of though
is that things will change and when that
happens i'll be right here in your
computer screen with a new video about
it thanks for watching and i will see
you in the next one